She was originally introduced as the daughter
of Batman and Catwoman, and made her way back
from being dead not once, but twice.
Let’s take a look at all the incarnations
of the Huntress.
Like a lot of the most confusing pieces of
the DC Universe, the Huntress has her roots
in Earth-2.
In her case, though, it's not just a simple
story of crossing dimensions.
More than anyone else, she shows how an attempt
to solve a storytelling problem that didn't
really matter gave DC the chance to take their
characters in some very unexpected directions.
It starts in the 1960s, when DC decided they
needed to explain why there were new characters
with the same names as a few of the old ones.
The extremely simple solution was to dive
headfirst into the idea of parallel worlds.
In the pages of Flash, a parallel world called
Earth-2 was created as a home for all of the
original versions of the DC superheroes.
Of course, the idea of Earth-2 also created
a few new problems, like how some of the Earth-2
heroes existed as fictional comic book characters
on Earth-1.
Barry Allen, for example, chose to name himself
"The Flash" because he'd read the same comics
about the original Flash, Jay Garrick, that
were published in the real world.
Apparently nobody ever read the ones about
how Batman and Superman were really Bruce
Wayne and Clark Kent.
One of the most interesting things about Earth-2
was that DC now had versions of its most popular
characters that could change in ways the ones
in the main stories never could.
Earth-2 Superman was happily married to Lois
Lane, while his Earth-1 counterpart was still
refusing to settle down as he waged his never-ending
battle against evil.
The same went for the Batman family.
Dick Grayson grew up, keeping his identity
as Robin into adulthood, and Bruce Wayne retired
from crime-fighting and married Selina Kyle,
better known as Catwoman.
Earth-2's Batman and Catwoman would even die
after their retirement, prompting an elderly
Joker to go on a rampage after being denied
a final clash with his arch-nemesis.
Long before that, however, Bruce and Selina
had a child together.
Her name was Helena Wayne, and as you might
expect, it wasn't long before she joined the
family business.
As a crimefighter, she took the name Huntress
and wore a costume that combined Batman's
pointy-eared look with Catwoman's traditional
purple.
What might be surprising, though, is that
she wasn't the kind of prominent character
you'd expect Batman and Catwoman's daughter
to become.
While she starred in a few stories and fought
crime alongside the grown-up Robin as the
"New Dynamic Duo," Helena Wayne's most prominent
appearances came when she took an interdimensional
vacation to Earth-1 to spend some time with
that world's version of her dad.
Of course, meeting up with the alternate reality
daughter you fathered with a supervillain
is always going to be a little weird, but,
you know.
It's the DC Universe.
You get used to stuff like that.
By the mid '80s, DC's Multiverse had expanded
well beyond Earth-2 into a whole roster of
alternate worlds built around different ideas.
"One where the Nazis won World War II, one
where Kennedy was never assassinated…”
“Oh yeah, one where all of us are evil.”
“Been there, it sucks."
In 1985, they tried to clean it all up with
a 12-issue event called Crisis on Infinite
Earths.
The ads for the series claimed that "worlds
will live, worlds will die, and the DC Universe
will never be the same," and while comic books
have often featured some taglines that went
way over the top, this one actually lived
up to it.
The main effect of the story was that the
Multiverse of parallel worlds was obliterated
and streamlined into a single unified timeline.
As a result, there was no more Earth-2 Batman,
because there was no more Earth-2 to be the
Batman of.
If Earth-2 didn't exist, then neither did
Helena Wayne.
It's worth noting that Huntress was one of
the few characters to survive the initial
destruction of her home dimension, finding
herself stranded alongside her Earth's Robin
on a strange world with no record of her existence.
With nothing left for her in the universe,
she joined Robin on a final, fatal mission.
The final indignity?
The story specifically states that her body
and Robin's were never recovered after their
deaths.
Here's the thing about superhero comics: nothing
ever really goes away, especially when it's
tied to a character as prominent as Batman.
With that in mind, it's no surprise that DC
brought back the Huntress only a few years
after Crisis.
What is surprising is that they completely
reinvented the character in almost every aspect,
aside from her costume and her first name
and even the costume underwent some radical
changes before too long.
Instead of being Batman's daughter, the post-Crisis
Huntress was something a little closer to
being DC's take on the Punisher.
Helena Bertinelli was the youngest member
of one of Gotham City's most prominent mobster
families in the years before Batman arrived,
and organized crime was mostly replaced by
evil clowns and mad scientists with ice guns.
When she was only eight years old, Helena's
entire family was murdered in front of her
by a hitman who left her alive as the only
survivor.
Helena was taken in by her family in Sicily,
who offered to train her so that she could
get her revenge, something that she took to
very well.
When she returned to Gotham, however, she
saw Batman in action, and realized that if
she really wanted to strike terror into the
hearts of the mobsters who had targeted her
family, she should follow in his footsteps
as a vigilante.
With that, she took the identity of the Huntress,
although that wasn't her only calling.
While she was wealthy enough to live off of
her family's ill-gotten gains, she actually
kept a day job as a school teacher, something
that would have more prominence in other versions
of the character.
You don't really get to be a vigilante in
Gotham City without attracting some attention
from the vigilante in Gotham City.
Sure enough, the new Huntress soon encountered
Batman.
The big sticking point between the two characters
comes from the way they deal with their enemies.
Most versions of Batman famously have a code
against killing.
"You finally learned to do what is necessary."
"I won't kill you."
The Huntress, on the other hand, has no problem
at all sending her opponents off to their
final reward.
Still, Batman didn't set out to take the Huntress
down.
After all, if there's one person who understands
the intense trauma of watching your family
get gunned down in front of you, and the anger
that can lead you to put on a costume and
wage war against all criminals by night, it's
that guy.
Still, he didn't approve of her methods, but
the solution he came up with for this particular
problem wasn't the one that anyone expected.
He let her join the Justice League.
Batman's hope was that membership in the JLA,
surrounded by paragons of virtue like Superman
and Wonder Woman, would be a good influence
on the Huntress and show her a different way
of fighting crime.
It did not work.
When Batman found her getting ready to execute
a helpless supervillain at the climax of one
of the League's biggest crises, he booted
her out of the league in disappointment.
Helena Bertinelli's relationship with the
rest of the Batman family is a little complicated.
We've already been through her rocky interactions
with the Dark Knight himself, but his sidekicks
tend to have a very different perspective
on the Huntress.
Tim Drake, for instance, had the sort of relationship
you'd expect from a super-smart teenage overachiever
and a world-weary teacher.
Her relationship with Dick Grayson, better
known as Nightwing, is… a little more mature.
When he first encountered the Huntress, they
had immediate chemistry, and they quickly
found themselves in a team-up with benefits.
An actual relationship didn't blossom out
of that encounter, though, partly because
of the time that Huntress accidentally shot
Batman with a crossbow in front of Nightwing.
There are definitely exceptions, but using
medieval weaponry on someone's beloved father
figure is going to be a dealbreaker.
Even more than Batman himself, Helena Bertinelli's
most complicated relationship within the Dark
Knight's group of assorted sidekicks was with
Barbara Gordon.
And before you start wondering, it actually
had very little to do with Barbara's on-again,
off-again relationship with Dick Grayson.
Instead, the biggest source of conflict came
from what was essentially the superheroic
equivalent of copyright infringement.
It happened in No Man's Land, a year-long
crossover event where a devastating earthquake
left Gotham City broken and abandoned by the
government.
After unsuccessfully campaigning to save the
city, Bruce Wayne was left dejected and depressed,
and even contemplated abandoning the city
himself, while supervillains carved Gotham
into their own little Fury Road territories.
While Batman was gone, a mysterious new Bat-person
appeared, who eventually turned out to be
the Huntress, using Batman's identity and
iconography to give hope to the remaining
citizens.
When Batman returned, he gave her his approval
to continue acting as the ersatz Bagirl, which
didn't sit well with Barbara.
Babs had been forced to give up being Batgirl
after being paralyzed by the Joker, and was
infuriated by the idea of Batman giving away
something that she still thought of as a big
part of her identity without even telling
her who was under the mask.
Eventually, around the same time that she
was fired from the JLA, Huntress gave up the
Batgirl identity voluntarily, but No Man's
Land also provided her with a measure of redemption
for what Batman had seen as her failings.
When the Joker launched a horrifying attempt
to murder every baby born in Gotham during
the No Man's Land year, Huntress made a heroic
last stand to protect the kids.
She wound up fighting a small army of Joker
impostors, and was shot by the real Joker
multiple times in the process.
Perhaps surprisingly, she survived the experience.
After the injuries she suffered in No Man's
Land, Helena Bertinelli made a full recovery,
and so did her relationship with Barbara Gordon...
for a while.
As Oracle, Barbara founded a team of her own
called the Birds of Prey, coordinating missions
with other superheroines as her operatives.
Having felt aimless for years after her experiences
in No Man's Land, the Huntress joined up alongside
Oracle and Black Canary.
The camaraderie of the team seemed to be doing
a lot of good for Helena, allowing her to
move past the anger and desire for revenge
that had driven her since she was a child.
Unfortunately, it was short lived.
After a few adventures with the Birds, she
realized that Oracle had been sending her
on missions designed to teach her lessons
and push her towards self-improvement, treating
her the same way that a teacher would handle
a problem student.
Infuriated at being manipulated by yet another
member of the Batman family who seemed to
want to mold her into what they wanted her
to be, she ditched the team and left.
In 2002, the WB launched a Birds of Prey TV
show, loosely and that's the key word there
based on comic of the same name.
"Who the hell are you?"
"I’m the Huntress.
And you're the prey."
The show focused on two heroines.
The first was Barbara Gordon, played by Dina
Meyer, who had been Batgirl until she was
shot by the Joker, and had reinvented herself
as Oracle.
The second, as though things weren't complicated
enough already, was Helena Kyle, played by
Ashley Scott.
Like the original Earth-2 Huntress, she was
the daughter of Batman and Catwoman, heavily
implied to be the versions seen on the big
screen in Batman Returns.
Unlike Helena Wayne, however, this version
never knew her father, with Catwoman keeping
her birth a secret from Batman.
Still, after Batman's apparent death, she
took the identity of the Huntress and carried
on his legacy alongside Barbara, protecting
a younger version of Black Canary, Dinah Lance.
The show only lasted a single 13-episode season
before it was canceled.
It did have some interesting ideas, however,
including casting a version of Harley Quinn
as the main villain of the series, marking
one of the first times she'd stepped out of
the Joker's shadow.
"Very witty, Quinzel"
"Oh, please, it’s Harley.
Harley Quinn.
And quite soon, this city, or what’s left
of it, will be mine."
It wasn't entirely forgotten, either 17 years
after the last episode aired, and only weeks
before the Huntress made it to the big screen
in the Birds of Prey movie, Ashley Scott returned
to the role for a cameo in CW's Crisis on
Infinite Earths crossover.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.